JACQUIN NILES:
All of my memories
are growing up in a really tiny,
British-dependent territory
called Anguilla.
To give you some
perspective, it's
about 35 square miles total
area, 36 during low tide.
People knew each other.
If you didn't know
them directly,
you knew who their family
and relatives were.
I became interested in medicine,
not just from the perspective
of understanding the
fundamentals of how biology
works in a living
entity, but also
the idea that it can go awry.
And how do you fix it?
Every year, about
700,000 or so, mostly
kids under the age of five, are
estimated to die from malaria.
Malaria is a parasitic disease.
It's caused by this family
of protozoan parasites.
A mosquito becomes
infected by feeding
on the blood of an
infected person.
That blood can contain
infectious forms
of a parasite that develops
within the mosquito,
and eventually will get
into the salivary glands
of the mosquito, and
then be transmitted back
to the blood of another
person who was bitten
by that infected mosquito.
Within the red cell, there's
an extremely high concentration
of hemoglobin, which contains
the co-factor heme that
is responsible, largely,
for the transport of oxygen
in the human body.
The parasite is able to degrade
the majority of the hemoglobin
within the red cell.
The heme, it has to deal with.
Because heme that
is not polymerized
has the ability to convert
molecular oxygen into more
reactive oxygen
species that can be
damaging to membranes,
proteins, DNA, et cetera.
And so the parasite
has devised a strategy
for polymerizing this
heme into this inert
polymer called hemozoin.
And that actually provides
an opportunity for us,
because if we can prevent
the polymerization of heme,
in principle, we can see the
toxicity of heme reemerging.
And so some of the
most successful
anti-malarial compounds,
such as chloroquine,
can actually bind heme and
prevent its polymerization.
And presumably, the
increased amount
of free heme that is produced
then kills the parasite.
Why I don't practice
medicine currently,
I think that's just been a
really valuable perspective
and a framework for
me to think about what
I do in the long term,
and how that can translate
into some impact on human life.